So welcome back to human emotion.
Today we're going to continue in our
third part of a three part series on
emotion elicitation and measurement.
Asking what makes us emotional.
So our first two modules
covered emotional elicitation,
looking at a diverse array of strategies
to trigger emotion both in and outside
of the lab. However, such techniques
are of little use in less.
We're also capable of reliably measuring
the emotion responses that we generate
using these tools.
So today what we're going to do is
focus on the ways in which we actually
measure the emotions once they're set off,
once they're triggered.
This is really using a multi componential
approach to motion that's going to
guide our roadmap today.
So first we'll try to look at ways in
which people measure the subjective
experience of emotion or how do I feel?
Then we'll look at the ways people
measure the outward expressive display of
emotional behavior. In other words,
how do I look when I feel emotional?
And finally we'll conclude by discussing
physiological ways of responding.
So physiological tools to measure emotion
in the autonomic and central nervous
system. Answering the question of what is
my body saying when I'm feeling I given
emotion? We'll conclude with our
takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's start with the
question of how do I feel?
How do we measure the subjective
experience of emotion?
So as we discussed earlier,
emotions have these multiple components.
So emotion needs to separately assess
each of these three components.
Here we're beginning with
subjective emotion response,
which is contrasted with behavioral
and physiological response domains.
When we think about subjective measures,
we can roughly break them
into three broad categories.
Self report questionnaires,
continuous rating,
dials and experience sampling methods
to capture emotion in everyday life.
So let's begin first with
some common questionnaires.
So one of the most common questionnaires
to assess both positive and negative
emotion experience is called the positive
and negative aspects schedule or the
Panis p a, n a. S. So it's
what you can see here.
There's a host of different
emotion related adjectives,
which participants are asked to
rate on a scale of very slightly,
a little moderately,
quite a bit or extremely.
And so they can answer this in terms
of what they're feeling. Right now,
what they felt in general in the
past week or at a trade level,
how they generally feel.
And this is probably the gold standard
for measuring subjective emotion
experience.
A new tool that's been developed that
we use often in my lab is called the
modified differential emotion scalar mds.
And what I particularly like about this
scale that you might be able to notice
as you're sort of scanning through the
different items here is that it has a
much more rich repertoire
of positive emotional terms.
So we see feelings of awe,
wonder, amazement, glad, happy,
joyful, interested, alert, curious.
So it comes in triplets and people are
asked to indicate to what extent they
feel from not at all to extremely hopeful,
optimistic slash encouraged as compared
to, for example, loves slash closeness.
Slash.
Trust.
And this is really nice if
you're particularly interested
in measuring discrete
or distinct types of positive emotional
experiences and using questionnaire
measures.
Okay.
Another commonly used questionnaire
measure is called the stress appraisal
measure or Sam. And what's nice
about this as it gets sort of, um,
over potential or across potential
language demands that may be inherent when
people are using either the Panis are
endless in terms of how they interpret
emotional words, um, and what their
emotional vocabulary is prior to the, uh,
you know,
experiment where they're filling out these
measures instead with the Sam uses as
a graphical icon of a human man,
good old Sam.
And what it's measuring really is
emotional activation or arousal.
So if you scan left to right,
you see someone at the left who's
not very emotionally activated,
very low arousal all the way up to the
right where it's extremely emotionally
activated. He's about to explode right
here from so much emotional intensity.
So this is a nice alternative if you
want to see to what extent, you know,
if you take language away and just use
graphical depictions of emotion related
intensity,
if you're able to get the same kind of
response that you would get using emotion
related adjectives. So, um,
let's think about questionnaires.
So there's different ways that you
can collect questionnaire responses.
One way is to use traditional
paper and pencil methods.
So bringing the questionnaires printed
out into the laboratory and have the
participants fill it out.
Much like the picture you see here.
So this is considered the traditional
way that's actually now becoming more of
the old school way.
So it seems more and more that
people are now collecting self report
questionnaires using computerized
online survey methods.
So one common use survey method
that people use as Qualtrics.
So Qualtrics is an example of how you
can actually program these questionnaires
using this interface and have people
instead of writing out the response,
simply click or select a particular
response option on the computer and then
have this particular online survey program
output the data for you in either a
very easily accessible excel,
SPSS or other type of format.
In addition, we see another method
that's gaining increasing attention,
which is Amazon's mechanical Turk.
So this is a very widespread
and ever-growing way to
collect data outside of
simply college undergraduate samples
from people around the world.
So you can distribute surveys and even
within the course of 24 hours have a
large number of self report
questionnaire responses.
So if you're interested
in more about this,
you can definitely look at some readings
that have suggested the potential power
of a tool like this for collecting
self report questionnaire. Assessment,
some emotion in a relatively
short time period.
Another method is called
narrative methods.
So this goes beyond general categories
to capture more nuance themes of a
person's unique emotional life. So
I particularly like this quote. Um,
this was a quote from the book living
narrative, and it goes as follows.
Putting events in a temporal sequence
not only orders them with respect to each
other, it creates an
overarching interpretive frame.
Just as a succession of notes does not
necessarily constitute a melodic phrase.
So events that are randomly recounted
do not make a story like notes.
The narrated events need to be
cast as members of an ordered set,
like a melodic phrase,
such as set,
constitutes a coherent narrative
unit called an episode.
So here what you're doing is
you're collecting people's
either verbal or written
descriptions of their emotional
experiences and you can code it, you know,
along rich dimension of,
of different categories.
You can look at the temporal
sequencing of the event,
sort of what's the linear trajectory
or lack thereof in which they tell the
story.
You can look at a particular kinds of
emotion words or metaphors people use. Um,
you can also look at the rich context
that they embed their emotions in and
whether they described their emotions as
being something that they're an active
agent over or simply a
passive recipient of.
So these are things that you simply can't
get using questionnaires and that you
can get using a narrative methodology.
Related to this,
Pennebaker has developed a computerized
system called the Luke l IWC linguistic
inquiry and word count.
And what he does using the system is
he's able to take text of people's either
verbal narratives of speeches that
have been transcribed or again,
people will do writing assignments.
And it's like the one in this slide where
there'll be asked to sort of keep an
emotional diary over a time period where
they record their deepest emotions and
thoughts about some
emotional upheaval. Um, in,
in his instructions he asks people to
really let go and explore the event and
how it has affected you. You might
tie this experience to your childhood,
your relationship with your parents,
people you have loved or love now or
even your career and to write every day
continuously for 20 minutes.
What he's done with this exercise is
taken people's written descriptions of the
emotional upheaval or difficulty
that they're currently confronting.
Put it through his computerized
text analysis system, the Luke,
and then looked at the prevalence of
things such as pronoun usage, using more,
for example,
I versus we words or looking at the
kinds of emotional words people use are
looking at the kind of insight that
develops in their sort of cognitive use of
language as they write about this event
every day for four consecutive days.
So he's able to actually see change
in people's emotional wellbeing as a
function of the language or ways in
which they described their emotional
experiences.
Now,
now we moved from questionnaires
and narrative methods,
Twitter called rating dials.
So you can see this here in the screen.
What rating dials do that's really
unique is they allow you to look at fine
grained, um, second by
second measurements of,
so here what you have people do
is while they're in a laboratory,
you have them place their hand on a dial.
So it may be one like the dial on the
left where they can move it from left to
right from very negative all the way
over to very positive or it can be more a
straight line.
Here we're very negative maybe at the
bottom and very positive at the top.
And this has been used in studies where
people are either watching dynamic films
over a several minute period or
interacting in discussions with partners.
And what people can do is literally
shift the dial second by second as their
emotion experience changes.
So all the methods we've talked about so
far are really looking at broader time
scopes,
asking people to write in that moment
how they felt on average or how they felt
during a,
you know,
emotional film after the film has ended
and what you miss out on are the fine
grain second by second changes or what
people call the aspect of chronometer.
Three of an emotion response.
Here you can look at not only how
intense someone felt in the motion,
but what were the patterns of variability.
How long did it take them to
reach their peak emotion state?
How long did it take them to recover?
You can answer a whole host of really
rich questions when you use continuous
styles like this.
The one disadvantage some people might
argue is that it may interfere with the
actual experience of the emotion.
So you can imagine being in a conversation
with someone while they're sharing a
distressing event and you may find
it cognitively difficult to both pay
attention to the individual speaking
and sort of keep your hand on this lever
constantly moving it around
is your emotion state shifts.
But these are some of the
rich possibilities that
you can really extract when
you use these, you know,
more continuous rating dials.
And then finally the third sort of common
measure of subjective spirits as you
can see here is what's called
experience sampling methods,
often referred to as ESM.
So ESM is a really fascinating way to
collect information about a person's
emotion state outside of the lab and
their own naturalistic daily life.
So here this is a type of data collection
in which participants respond to
repeated assessments at moments over
the course of time while functioning and
living within their natural life settings.
So people originally would do ESM
studies starting with the alarm clock,
stacks of paper, palm pilot, pagers.
And today with all the
advances of technology,
there is now iPhone apps that people can
use to report over multiple times in a
given day at random intervals. How are
they feeling? What contexts are they in?
What kinds of strategies are they using
to effectively manage their emotions?
So what's Nice is that people can
respond directly to these devices.
It's time saving. It's convenient
often for participants to do it.
At their own time and their own life.
And what you can then do is just transfer
the state data relatively easily to a
computer for subsequent data analysis.
So this is one of the ways to sort of
get outside of the lab and try to capture
people's emotions as it's actually
lived in their daily life force.
The subjective experience of,
so for example,
um,
some of the things that experience
sampling methods provide, um,
are the following in addition to some
of the advantages I just highlighted.
So experience sampling methods one,
allow you to understand
behavioral contingencies.
So you can look at the
relationship between the
subjective experience of emotion
and the actual events occurring in their
lives and try to find some important
causal link between what happens in your
life and how that causes you to feel or
at least understand the association
between the two. Second,
it has good ecological validity. So this
is a term we've heard a lot in this,
you know, three part module on
emotional elicitation and measurement,
which really means how again,
how much does it map onto the
person's own real world experience.
Because here you're getting people to
get outside of the lab in their own
naturalistic every day environment.
Third,
what you can do here,
since you're getting multiple measures
of emotion within a single participant
across, you know, a wide, uh, period
of time, maybe a couple of days,
all the way up to a week or a month as
you can investigate what's referred to as
intra individual processes.
So this is within person processes such
as differences within a person that can
change over time or across the situation.
So we can all think of ways in which our
own mood may fluctuate over the course
of a day or in response to
different kinds of events.
And Esm lets you actually
look at that scientifically.
So we've talked a little bit about
subjective measures of or how we feel.
Now let's move to behavioral
measures or how do we look,
how do we behave when we're feeling
emotional? So behavioral measures, um,
some of the two most common use tools
in this domain are the facial action
coding system and the staff system.
So we'll talk about each of these in turn.
So we'll begin with the fax system.
So this is one of the first systems
that was developed to systematically
quantify emotion expressions in the face.
So it was developed by Paul Ekman and
freezing in the 1970s and what it did is
tried to categorize facial behaviors,
not based on overall sort of subjective
impressions of how emotional the
person's face looked,
but instead based on a more sort of
micro level rigorous coding of the
underlying muscle configurations that
are used to give rise to an emotion
expression.
So every little sort of unit of muscle
action he would say is what he called an
action unit or Aau and specific action
units where specific a use he would argue
combined together to reflect emotions.
So we'll go through an example of
what kind of a use, for example,
give rise to the expression
of happiness when we smile.
Now facts is incredibly rigorous and often
considered a gold standard and coding
emotional behavior in the face,
but it comes at the cost.
So it takes 80 to a hundred
hours to train on the system.
And once you've gone
through the training manual,
you have to pass a nationwide standardized
certified test become what's called a
official facts coder.
So this is something that myself
and my students in my lab have done.
And it's a considerable time investment.
But once you do it,
it changes the way you
look at the face forever.
You notice subtle muscle shifts all around
in the face that we often, you know,
maybe barely detect or go unnoticed.
And this particular system allows
you to capture them, notice them,
and quantify them.
So let's look at an example here.
So hugely an expression of a
woman looking, for example,
you might say she looks scared.
Now,
what are the particular muscle units in
our face that make her look that way?
So here these codes here, one
c, two c, five d, et Cetera,
these are the action units. So the action
units or the particular numbers here,
one, two, five, four,
20 etc. And the letters next to them
refer to the intensity of the display.
So they go from a,
which is sort of at the lowest sense.
So it's a trace all the
way up to [inaudible],
which is the maximal intensity of how
much you could contract that muscle.
So you see a c here that's
somewhere in the middle.
So she's raising her inner eyebrow
at a moderate degree, right?
And it really tries to code
all of these separately,
not looking so much at overall,
how do we think she's feeling,
but what specific muscles are being
activated and contracted while that
particular expression is occurring.
Now here,
what's interesting is that you can use
facts to reliably identify what's called
a real smile or a Duchenne smile.
So what are the characteristics of someone
when they're smiling authentically?
Well,
there's two distinguishing features.
One of them is called the
Aau six or the cheek racer.
Now this in older adults,
older than this young girl here,
we also call it the crows feet.
So when we raise our cheeks up,
what often happens in us older adults
is you see fine lines develop on the
corner of the eyes.
And so that's one kind of telltale
sign that it's a genuine smile.
And you also see what's called an Aau
12 which is really taking the corners of
the lips and pulling them upwards.
What we often think of as a smile.
So this is a genuine smile.
How do we contrast this then with
a fake or non Duchenne smile?
So what do you notice here? What is
different from the picture you just saw?
So those of you who said,
hey,
the Aau six is missing are exactly right.
So these kind of fake smiles we do for
photos or an awkward social situations,
what we're doing is we're trying
to pull the lip corners up,
but we're not able to move our cheeks up.
We're not able to kind of get those
crow's feet, you know, in action.
And that's because Paul Ekman and others
would argue that a genuine smile is not
something that we can voluntarily produce.
It's actually something
that's quite involuntary and
usually only co occurs when
we're genuinely feeling happy.
So if you want to know how to detect
a real smile from a fake smile,
look for the [inaudible] that she
grazer that you see. Not In this man,
but you see in this young girl here, okay,
so now let's look at the staff system.
So the spouse systems really fantastic
and includes additional codes that aren't
inherent in the fact system.
And as you can see here,
some of the additional codes that are
included in this bath system and that were
really developed to help measure emotional
behavior in the context of dyadic
interactions.
Frequently between romantic partners or
spouses are additional behavioral and
even auditory cues.
So it will have postural codes such as
when someone sits up or forward when
they're talking to their spouse,
it'll try to get at intonation.
So whether or not there are changes in
a person's vocal pitch or whether they
were speaking at a different volume and
also gets at what a really important
emotional behaviors such as laughter,
which the fax system
does not itself code as,
it's only coding the ways in which the
face is contracting in terms of the
underlying musculature. So spath is also
fantastic to use and as you can see,
it's based off the fact system.
You see the same Aau six and a 12,
but it has additional codes here.
So you can see the man on the right.
This is Jim Coan. Um, a wonderful
aspect of scientists in the field.
And you see here not
only the Aau six and 12,
but also additional descriptions of
things that are associated with interest,
affection, validation,
humor and enthusiasm.
And we might also look at whether or not
he's showing an increase in his vocal
pitch, looking at his posture as he's
sitting up and forward, et cetera.
So now we've talked about subjective
and behavioral. What about our body?
How does our body say anything about the
way we feel emotionally and how do we
measure that? So I'll start
here with our bodily sensations.
Looking at the question of,
you know,
can things like our heart rate or a
heartbeat actually really be a window into
our feelings?
So William James,
really the father of psychology first
echo this notion that indeed the body is a
window into the emotional soul.
He said,
no shade of emotion should be without
some sort of bodily reverberation or some
way in which our body shifts or sort
of undulates when we feel an emotion
response,
and we'll talk about this more in the
course will actually have a specific
lecture devoted to this.
Where we look at this question of is a
heart really a window into our feelings
and we'll also look at the specific kinds
of tools that people measure emotion
in the lab. As you can see here, this is
actually one of my research assistants,
Christina reas and she has
a variety of electrodes,
are sensors that are attached.
And what these sensors do is they pick
up electrical activity of the heart every
time, the heartbeats as well as looking
at different respiration patterns.
So you can see here in this graph
are things like the heartbeat.
So the red signal here and every little
blue.at the top is it is a distinct
point at which her heartbeats
and what you can do,
and we'll talk again about this
in more depth when we get to the
psychophysiology of emotion.
As you can map specific types of
autonomic nervous system or ans changes to
emotion responses.
So we can try to map specific
physiological profiles of anger, fear,
sadness,
disgust,
and even happiness simply based on
changes in our bodily responses.
So that's the peripheral
autonomic nervous system.
What about the central nervous system
or the brain? So there's, you know,
three kind of major divisions of the
brain that are thought to be included in
emotion.
So this includes the limbic system.
So this includes the hypothalamus
and Mig, Dulla, nucleus accumbens,
and several other nearby areas and has
great importance in emotional life and
memories for emotional events.
As you can see here.
Second is the stride
system or the striatum.
So this includes the putamen
caught a nucleus nucleus accumbens,
and it's divided into both the
dorsal and ventral striatum.
As you can see roughly here,
and this is often thought of as
the reward center of the brain.
So it's often associated with the
experience of pleasure or reward.
And third is the NEOCORTEX.
So this is the outer layer of the
brain as you can roughly see here,
deeply folded and grooved.
And here are the prefrontal cortex is
in the front part of the brain and we
think of this as sort of the
prefrontal cognitive control region.
So this is thought to be involved in
the regulation or control of emotion.
Each of these three subdivisions of the
brain will also go much further into
depth when we get to the
brain basis of emotion.
But I want you to see today as there's
really rich complex tools to study bodily
changes,
both in our autonomic nervous system
and higher up in our brain that indeed
provide clues into our
emotional wellbeing.
Yeah,
the central nervous system,
we can look at responses using things
called functional magnetic resonance
imaging or Mri.
Here we can look at areas of the
brain that seem to be activated during
different kinds of emotional
challenges or stressors.
Okay.
And we can also use Brainly's lesion.
Patient patients such as old Phineas gage,
who had a naturally occurring legion in
his orbital frontal cortex while working
on a railroad and after this lesion was
found to have profound changes in his
behavior.
So he was an uninhibited,
more aggressive and seem to just be
less emotionally regulated than he was
before. And you can also look at
areas of damage as well as um,
areas of disease as well.
So we've briefly touched on subjective,
behavioral and physiological
ways to measure emotion as
an introduction into the
emotion response system.
So now turn to our takeaway questions.
Yeah.
So the first takeaway question really
just has you recap what were the three
types of subjective emotion measures
discussed today. The second asks,
what are the two major behavioral
coding systems of emotion,
really prominent tools in the field
that were discussed in this lecture.
And finally,
how can the physiological body,
both in the autonomic or peripheral
nervous system as well as the central
nervous system actually be a potential
way to reflect our inner emotional life.
And with that,
I will now segue to our expert interview.
This is part of our experts in emotion
interview series where we're going to be
exploring questions about emotion
through the eyes of some of the most
distinguished scholars in the field.
So today we'll be speaking with doctor
iris smells on emotion measurement.
So doctor mouse received her phd from
Stanford University and is currently an
assistant professor of psychology at UC
Berkeley where she directs the emotion
and emotion regulation laboratory.
Dr. Miles is an expert in the nature
of emotion and emotion regulation.
And her work has forged exciting new
paths and measuring emotion response,
examining coherence between
different components of emotion,
looking at the measurement
and elicitation of anger,
and more recently the pursuit of
happiness and how it relates to our mental
health and wellbeing.
So I now turn to an incredibly special
experts and emotion interview with Doctor
Iris Mouse on emotion measurement.